the Joe Rogan experience you have to
find someone first of all it's gonna be
able to deal with the fact that you're a
comic right yeah that's you're dating
other comics which I am well that's good
I guess everyone's like don't do that
I'm securing christina pazsitzky one of
the best couples at Moshe kasher and
Natasha Leggero Grammy and Rich yes
great great couple it's possible yeah
and obviously they're the people that
are gonna understand you yes I
understand what you do but like a
regular dude is gonna have a problem
with you being the funny one like a lot
of dudes have a problem you know but
sometimes some people like are fine with
it like Eliza
Eliza's husband he's a chef he's super -
great that guy's awesome I know he
really is he's so chill he just like
hangs like it's a perfect complement to
her personality yeah so brash and
outrageous and you know and she's so
powerful and he's just like mellow dude
you know I was like hanging out and you
know it's like they work together yes
he's not a weak man he's just calm you
know and they work together right you
gotta find someone like that you got to
find someone who who complements your
personality in a way yeah but it's just
like I don't know how you meet someone
like that when you're a girl comedian I
think women comedians it's a unique
requirement that you have for other
people because the thing where men
always want to be the center of
attention right the man wants to be the
Alpha they want to be the one who's
talking like clink-clink-clink ladies
and gentlemen we have you know Bob's
gonna give a toast here if you want to
be that [ __ ] and when you got a wife
or a girlfriend who's a [ __ ] way
funnier than you not only she's funnier
than you she's [ __ ] funny
professionally yeah I'm funnier than
everyone that isn't a comic and then a
lot of comics do like it's like people
like you need to convene I'm like I'll
be funnier than two it's are it is hard
and you're so right about that like I
see how much [ __ ] men get thrown at
them doing stand-up because even I get
wet first stand-ups like I know the
tricks and I'll be watching a guy with
like killing there's there's so much
attraction when you
see an audience all like watching this
dude on stage and he's commanding them
with laughter and telling you know
controlling their emotions you just get
wet for cuz you're like he's it's
cavewoman brain it's like he's our tribe
leader right he's the leader I need to
[ __ ] him he's gonna protect me during
wartime like that's the difference in
men and women because men don't get that
when a woman yes be in the kitchen yeah
I remember Theo von telling me recently
he was like I hated your comedy and I'm
like what why he's like I did not like
you when yeah and I go well I've always
been funny so I don't understand in your
commute you're funny seen funny knows
funny he's like it wasn't that it was
just like your voice like reminded me of
like my mom or something is my mom's
always yelling at me and I was like
there it is even was like I can't
believe I'm saying this to you and I was
like I like it because yeah we remind
you of your mom's female comics if
you've been an overbearing mom telling
you like it is what it is all the time
shut the [ __ ] up ladies I hate female
comics if I Adam an overbearing mother
so I empathize with that Theo is so
crazy it's all [ __ ] crazy
he's so crazy he's funny though he's
just so ridiculous O'Neal like I don't
know anybody that has his style even
remotely his style is so uniquely him
it's so hard to be that unique and you
watch him and you're like yeah this
isn't cultivated this isn't was its who
yeah it's just who he is how he does and
he was able to that's not easy to do as
be as funny as you are with your friends
on stage and he's worked really hard at
it and he's just he's nailed it
[Applause]